so what defines a forist candidate uh if
for if people want to to see whether it
might be a fit for them so we're doing
two things that are really interesting
first of all we I can I can give you the
the rough outlines of of what we're
looking for in candidates and I think
that people to some degree can look at
you and me and Christy Witman and and
and others who who've run uh who are on
the board and say okay I think I
understand what a Ford candidate stands
for but first and foremost we're
interested in strengthening democracy
and defending democracy we believe in
the Constitution we believe in rule of
law you know we believe that everyone is
equal under the law and should be
treated equally under the law you know
we believe that there should be open
primaries so so that PE the best people
can emerge from that primary system so F
the first part of who the our candidates
are is really that support for democracy
Democratic reforms anti-german mandering
and so forth um the second part is that
we want collaborative problem solvers we
want people who genuinely want the
trains to run on time and it to be on
budget we want people who are looking
for the best Solutions not just their
Solutions and sometimes those Solutions
might be ones that have been floated by
the Republicans or by the Democrats or
maybe they're entirely new and no one
has ever heard of this solution before
and it doesn't really fit in any bin but
it's a good solution and we should think
about it and so we want open-minded
problem solvers if you think about it
most of our problems are really local
problems we need candidates who can
solve local problems as well as as a
good mayor is worth his or her weight in
gold you know what I mean like a good
school board as a parent I mean I've got
chan in public school like a good school
board is worth it's weight and gold
exactly and so then the last thing that
we're looking for is candidates of good
character people who can genuinely be
role models
and who can restore that faith in
government that that people have lost we
need people who are going to be ethical
we need people who are going to uh bring
out our bet better Angels instead of
trying to uh win by appealing to our
baser instincts those are the kinds of
characteristics that we're looking for
and in terms of policy we're going to
have a really interesting process where
we Bubble Up from the states and from
our individual for members uh online
what you know what issues and what
policies are most appealing and
concerning to them I think that that is
going to make us unique among all of the
policies you know among all of the
parties because you know where else can
we actually say that the policies of a
party are connected with the beliefs and
the concerns of the members I think both
the Republican party and Democratic
party have lost contact entirely you
know with their membership so so we're
uh we're excited about doing that and
we're going to be rolling that out in
the next couple months we're going to
build a like a whole ladder uh you know
and and it's uh always vital to have
people doing great work where we live um
uh and also to be developing uh the the
Next Generation and over the last couple
of years we already now have dozens of
elected officials who are affiliating
with forward uh state senators in
Pennsylvania state legislators in
Arizona
May Mayors in Florida and Connecticut
and Colorado so we have um already the
this mini Cadre of uh of officials and
then we're going to grow it tremendously
thank you for those of you who have
donated we have uh recognition in South
Carolina um Utah Florida like in in
different states around the country in
different ways like some of it's minor
party recognition um some of it's more
significant in South Carolina it's full
um you know I might be in South Carolina
as as this gets
aired in another in another two or three
years we should have ballot access in
every state yeah exactly so you know so
we we we are adding another state to our
list of places where we can have forward
candidates on the ballot every couple
months so we're um we're we're rolling
in our and our volunteers are so excited
and dedicated to what they're doing so I
we would love for anyone who is
interested in being a forward candidate
at any level uh to reach out to us um we
should have a a cool uh forward party
email address for them right now and I'm
going to make it up and by the time this
airs it's going to be real uh candidates
forpart do.com um so just email
candidates forp party.com and then that
will go to the
team hey YouTube thanks for watching
please do hit like And subscribe and hit
that Bell if you want to be notified
every time a new episode drops thank
you